are you single I'm so single too oh my
God we need to tear up this town are you
are you looking for a relationship or
are you happy as the things are are you
open to it what are you you know I'm
um
I'm still processing I'm I feel very
free
I feel liberated I feel like I just
like a whole weight was lifted off of me
in a way she lives a couple hundred
pounds oh my God form of a human it's so
good right yeah it's so good like I'm
wearing my old jeans again it's good
yeah oh yeah oh it's nice when it
affects you that way yeah yeah because
I've gone the other way well no I broke
up
like you know what
you know what I'm thinking yeah
yeah babe work it out work it out